Mary and the witches flower comes to us
from the director of The Secret World of
Arrietty and when Marnie was there two
films I really liked especially Marnie
and this film follows Mary a young girl
with very messy hair who doesn't have
too many friends who follows a cat into
the woods one day and finds a flower
that she doesn't recognize and when she
breaks one of the bulbs of this flower
this substance gets all over her and she
suddenly has all of these magical
abilities she gets transported to this
different realm and this leads to a
fantastical adventure where she tries to
figure out if she wants to be her old
klutzy self or this new powerful witch
when Hayao Miyazaki originally said he
was going to retire after the wind rises
he has since said he will make one more
film members of Studio Ghibli left and
formed studio panic and this is Studio
ponics first film so naturally I'm
ecstatic that a new studio has been
formed to continue the studio ghibli
legacy and hopefully the following films
are a little better than Mary and the
witch's flower because this film is
beautiful and stunning and has some
incredible moments the musical score
being one of my favorites of recent
anime films I've seen but the script and
the characters needed a lot of work
there's things to love about Marian the
witch's flower and most of it has to do
with the technical aspects of the film
on display I'm never gonna get tired of
films that look this beautiful of
animation that leaps off the screen like
this that has such enthralling action
sequences but in the long run the film
was disappointing because I just didn't
care that much about Mary the main
character and her hero's journey is
strangely murky she stumbles across this
flower which gives her these abilities
she doesn't know what's going on and
it's not something she has to earn
suddenly she's transported to this place
that might as well be Hogwarts where you
see people learning about Witchcraft and
Wizardry there's even a character with
glasses seen trying to ride a broom that
looked so much like Harry Potter I
couldn't help but think it was a
tongue-in-cheek reference and when she's
wandering this school everyone seems so
impressed by her abilities when she
knows it's just from this flower she
touched
so in some ways it relates to superhero
tales because people like Peter Parker
obviously got bit by a spider and
suddenly now he has to deal with these
abilities most superhero films are like
that or comic books where you have a
character that encounters something or
stumbles across something and all of a
sudden they have this incredible
responsibility they have to bear on
their shoulders the difference between
Mary and some of those comic book heroes
is that Mary doesn't have that much
actual drama in her life and so
obtaining these new abilities it's just
sort of this fun new thing she has where
she can do these things for a night and
then they go away
what's so integral to stories like this
where you have a character that
encounters something that changes their
life is the journey they take how much
they change how much it alters them what
does the character learn without getting
into spoilers the last thing Mary says
in this movie lets you know that she
didn't really learn much of anything and
beyond one noble decision she makes I
can't really see young girls looking to
Mary and saying I want to be like Mary
because there isn't that much about her
that makes her stand out she's a
likeable young girl who clearly wants to
make an impression she wants to help a
lot of the first act is her trying to
sweep up or help with gardening and she
fails because she's just not that good
at anything and so the idea for getting
these abilities and suddenly being able
to do all these things is cool but she
doesn't really seem to learn all that
much from them it just kind of feels
like something she stumbled across and
doesn't really do much with it would be
like if Luke Skywalker went off to learn
about the force but he sort of takes a
pill that allows him to have the
abilities and then at the end of the
film he's like yeah all right I'm just
gonna go back to tad away to be a farmer
again and he doesn't really do that much
with his abilities also disappointing
were the villains in the film once you
learn their scheme and you see the
choices they make to try to create
something in the name of science you
recognize that what they're doing is an
abomination again
mankind against animals but beyond that
their end goal is so unclear that you
can't really understand their motivation
either and a film that has villains that
are doing evil things and their
motivation is rather lacking that's not
a good idea for your villain the opening
scene of this film was glorious I
thought to myself oh my god this is
going to be great but it really goes
downhill after that
and in retrospect once you learn about
the backstory that you see in the
opening scene I think I'd rather see
that story that would be a much better
film than the one we actually got things
that mary learns along the way about
herself and about her family history
should be a lot more impactful than they
are for her character and for us as a
viewer so in the end this film
disappointed me from an audio and a
visual standpoint it's amazing it's just
that the characters really are the major
disappointment here the hero and the
villains I'm gonna give Marion the
witch's flower a C+ if you're a fan of
films like this do check it out because
you might have a different opinion than
I do guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
iced
[Music]